the modern era of vr basically started
with my e3 demo of doom 3 on the rift
prototype so we're like first person
shooters in vr match made in heaven
right
and that didn't work out that way at all
they have you know they have the most
comfort problems with it and then the
most popular virtual reality app is beat
saber which nobody predicted back then
was that make you
uh like
from first principles if you were to
like reverse engineer that why
are these like silly fun games the most
it actually makes very clear sense when
you when you analyze it from from
hindsight and look at the engineering
reasons where it's not just that it was
a magical quirky idea it was something
that played almost perfectly to what
turned out to be the real strengths of
vr where the one thing that i really
underestimated importance in vr was the
importance of the controllers you know i
was still thinking we could do a lot
more with with the gamepad and just the
amazingness of taking any existing game
being able to move your head around and
look around that that was you know that
was really amazing but the controllers
were super important but the problem is
so many things that you do with the
controllers just
suck it feels like it breaks the
illusion like trying to pick up glasses
with the controllers where you're like
oh use the grip button when you're kind
of close and it'll snap into your hand
all of those things are unnatural
actions that you do them and it's still
part of the vr experience but
beat saber winds up by playing only to
the strengths it completely hides all
the weaknesses of it because you are
holding something in your hand you keep
a solid grip on it the whole time it
slices through things without ever
bumping into things you never get into
the point where you know i'm knocking on
this table but in vr my hand just goes
right through it so you've got something
that slices through so it's never your
brain telling you oh i should have hit
something you've got a lightsaber here
it's just you expect it to slice through
everything
uh audio and music turned out to be a
really powerful aspect of virtual
reality where you're blocking the world
off and constructing the world around
you
and i and being something that can run
efficiently on even this relatively
low-powered hardware and can have a
valuable loop in a small amount of time
where a lot of modern games you're
supposed to sit down and play it for an
hour just to get anywhere sometimes new
game takes an hour to get through the
tutorial level and that's not good for
vr for a couple reasons you do still
have the comfort issues if you're moving
around at all but you've also got just
you know discomfort from the headset
battery lifespan on the mobile versions
so having things that do break down into
three and four minute windows of play
that turns out to be very valuable from
a gameplay standpoint
so it winds up being kind of a perfect
storm of all these things that are
really good it doesn't have any comfort
problems you're not navigating around
you're standing still all the stuff
flies at you it has placed audio
strengths i it adds the whole fitness in
vr nobody was thinking about that back
in the at the beginning and it turns out
that that is an excellent daily fitness
thing to be doing if you go play uh an
hour of beat saver or supernatural or
something that is legit solid exercise i
and it's more fun than doing it just
about any other way there so that's kind
of the arcade stage of things
if i were to say with my experience with
vr
the thing that i think is powerful is
the
maybe it's not here yet but the degree
to which it is immersive in the way
that quake is immersive it takes you to
another world for me because i'm a fan
of role playing games
uh the elder scrolls series uh like
skyrim or even daggerfall it just takes
you to another world and when you're not
in that world you miss not being there
and then you just you kind of want to
stay there forever because life is
shitty
you